they're good at that but they don't have
great senses of humor yeah so then
you're just kind of there and yeah
Eagles and [ __ ] muffins from craft
service and you're just getting [ __ ]
fat yeah I don't get fat ankles Mia but
you shredded but but no no no no but you
know I'm shred you lost a lot of weight
though I did yeah so what's the deal
psoriasis so I mean no bread and stuff
so you get psoriasis if you eat bread
yeah so I have to eat a certain diet pop
you start [ __ ] pops a super lean no
no is it that or is it just that you
don't be careful Milo I mean what the
more and more every when I and I'm not
saying you look a lot like this person
but them every time I see you in
something I'm not
this is I'm not you know like
something's going it's actually not I
know what you're saying but uh but I
feel like you're gonna be insulting I
get it III know I would feel that way
too but this is my cat so you're I know
okay I'm a guest of the fighter in the
kit yeah okay don't be a dick I'm not
okay
the every time I see you you look more
like the Cryptkeeper from and you look a
lot like it but it's more more yeah you
know they you know they told you not to
me I told you not to be involved no no
so why did you say that um you know what
he put no I'm saying you know any pops
up yeah he's a skeleton look at
everything I look like that the UM
tells from the Crypt Keeper he had a
good run I mean I'm not I'm not like he
was popular he's popular
I think they're redoing it so maybe you
why don't you shave while you let it
grow all the way down to your neck don't
have time you have nothing but time to
busy you have nothing but time
hey dude if I [ __ ] whatever what am I in
[ __ ] NSYNC let me tell you something
dude if you put any time into your beard
put a vest with a bunch of pockets on it
on and take a hike dude take a [ __ ]
hike what a vest with a bunch of pockets
on it oh come on put it on take
hi bro wait just let your beard grow up
that way bro your walking stick dude I
would never put lines or any sort of
care into my beer because of my [ __ ] in
the way dude I'm a [ __ ] guy I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna French it up get out
of here dude get outta here I'm gonna
[ __ ] bread I'm gonna [ __ ] French
head up dude I'm not singing a pie i
tailor my beer don't meet that doesn't
mean I'm French this is it eh yeah I
mean you see I'm not a French man [ __ ] I
keep breaking in French and I was sorry
dude don't play back in black it's gonna
make me mad know what I was going to do
is all right this is what I was going to
do did what see the sound effects I mean
just because you tailor your beard I
don't Oh Oh [ __ ] alert your oh you cut
your beard yeah I do i I'm an accurate
sometimes well don't do what I manicure
my beard sometimes Oh [ __ ] alert don't
just shave it and let it go Devils what
you do you can also there's nothing
wrong with bringing it down and keeping
a nice line here dude that is obnoxious
it did what do you do you dude get up
what do you do you shame for you Ikes
I'll pepper your shave let your cheek so
they don't go too high
yeah dude Fei Fei stop I can't wait to
get [ __ ] dude you know what I am ring
with me bro
what what you say to me why don't you
get in the ring with me bro bro nah by
the way you get beard up real nice for
that wouldn't you yeah
that you as it's a gift it's a gift it's
a gift